[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la
dilution france bleu n'ont pas laissé
planer en france alors bon je pars de
rien c'est vrai elle ne sait pas
toujours ce qu'elle dit où ça mais bien
le jeudi 28 septembre thomas sotto soeur
d'octobre
mais ça passe et on est bientôt
vous le savez c'est dimanche que sourire
en écosse la coop 26 en présence de plus
de 120 chefs d'état et de gouvernement
l'objectif est d'obtenir qu'il déshonore
la promesse faite à paris il y a 6 ans
de limiter un degré et demi le
réchauffement climatique et pour
rappeler l'urgence de la situation et
les nations unies ont lancé une vidéo
[Musique]
soyouz
en soin de toi
[Musique]
ça
pourquoi il faut fermer les abattoirs
moi je réponds oui et valérie non les
abattoirs dans l'évent vérité tu vas
être comblé mais j'assume j'ai enlevé
arrête tu as suivi à rennes on arrête
d'être démago comme ça à l'arrivée dans
les reer est insupportable cinq
centrales je trouve pas aux
excuses moi jle mais la chute est
insupportable en s'imposant très
tranquille ici tu poses ton cul sur la
chaise était content de travailler et
penser à dia plein de gens qui
travaillent et qui ont besoin de
travailler la règle de dire des
conneries l'image du jour c'est ce coup
de gueule que dis je ce coup de gueule
d'anne hidalgo parce qu'à un moment
donné ça va quoi parce que bon
alors je suis à la gare de saint vallier
mais quand les machines remplacent les
humains ça va parfois séquence touchante
hier anne hidalgo a découvert
l'existence des distributeurs
automatiques de billets ter c'est
poignant vivement la suite les enfants
sont déjà très exposé d un an d un an et
demi aux écrans mais même dès la
naissance avec la télé allumée au salon
nous sommes dans une société hyper
connectés les enfants se développe dans
une famille prennent des habitudes de la
famille et les parents sont hyper
connecté le cerveau prive le les écrans
prive le cerveau des besoins essentiels
du tout petit c'est à dire d'interagir
avec des humains en face à face surtout
ses parents et de découvrir le monde en
trois dimensions le monde réel avec tous
ses sens
a je pense que là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des retards de langage et sans fond qui
parle pas du tout où qui parle comme
leur baby tablette bloup apple va la vie
recommence ou bien des retards
intellectuelle puisque les connexions
dans le cerveau ne peuvent pas se faire
des retards moteur puisque les gestes
sont extrêmement pauvres sur les écrans
alors qu'enfin il a besoin de tous
manipulés et puis des troubles graves de
la relation et de la communication je l
ai déjà dit en 2010 m qu'on peut
confondre avec l'autisme puisque les
enfants sont captés par l'écran donc moi
il faut savoir que j'ai un meilleur ami
gilles aînés toujours avec moi c'est mon
meilleur pote c'est le téléphone alors
je pose toutes les questions à chaque
fois qu'il ya un truc couche bloc je
pose la question il ya une chanson quand
j'étais jeune c'était laisse pas traîner
ton fils c'est dieu bail qui disent
alors ça fait quoi d'être citée deux
fois par gérald darmanin j'ai des bons
des directs
[Rires]
la première vue ce sont des photos comme
il y en a des millions sur les réseaux
sociaux sauf que derrière cette
influence américaine de 20 ans il ya le
cercueil ouvert de son père un shooting
photos totalement décalé est accompagnée
d'une légende le papillon s'est envolé
repose en paix papa tu étais mon
meilleur ami une vie bien vécu la
publication de jane instagram euse de
miami a suscité un tollé au point
qu'elle désactive son compte ce nouveau
monde me laisse un peu perplexe je fais
tout pour ne pas être un vieux con
vraiment donc j'essaie de syrie aurait
parfois mais parfois c'est ce que je
veux améliorer et vous internes et des
tas de choses mais vous les faites quand
même bah ouais c'est le propre de la
jeunesse
a en tout cas
déjà évoqué non je représente en
mauvaises incitations
pardon pendant moi j'allais vous faire
des conflits mois à
7 ans vous l'aviez déjà évoqué dans
mauvaise réputation c'est un livre qui
m'avait bouleversé il ya quinze ans et
qui fait que depuis je vous aiment
inconditionnellement
voilà ce que j'allais dire joey starr
cassation n'ont absoluement soir
hamon faux pas en guerre quant à
[Musique]
eux deux
dans cette vidéo diffusée sur les
réseaux sociaux par le club du joueur
josh cavallo explique les raisons qui
l'ont poussé à sortir du silence
quant à m
je suis fatigué d'essayer donner le
meilleur mais capacité de vivre cette
double vie intérieure et les
aides s'il était présent et c'est
quelque chose que je ne souhaite à
personne
je vais faire mon coming out de mode
très bien mais on rigole hervé robbe
annoncer des choses sérieuses à joey on
est sérieux mais comme sur top gear bon
les des vrais gars te dire une mission
d'hommes
avant chaque tournage on prend des
p'tits déj de mode un petit coin temps
avec mon frère d'armes les routiers bon
les gars qu'est ce qu'on fait la
mode hier écrivait souvenez vous du côté
de la barbe et la toute puissance alors
allez dans la romaine en tout cas
affiché ses poils ça signifie qu'on
entre dans la vie sexuelle les poils
signal l'apparition et bien d'un
tempérament masculin si tant est qu'il
existe et des testicules une pierre deux
coups quand on connaît bien la pétanque
l'été dès qu'il fait chaud on n'a qu'une
envie c'est sortir ses boules
c'est l'humour du nord ça doit être
facile pour un grand sportif comme vous
de battre saison en neige plage fait
marcher mais bicesse maîtrise eve son
quadriceps alors on échoue
alors prêt à retourner votre saladier
une dessus de votre tête pour le fameux
test de consistance
c'est bon
je ne cherche un batteur
[Musique]
non à nouasser fait mal nietzsche
elle en a vu de toutes les couleurs
en mai rue de temps combat et a
tellement entendu son coeur
temps se pencher dans la poussière elle
dit qu on peut toujours je leur fait que
je me suis trompé
allez-y on a vu de dessus des douleurs
[Musique]